they tear themselves in half each half  regenerates the missing piece and now  you've got two that's how they reproduce  so if you're going to do that what you  end up avoiding is weissman's barrier  this idea that when we get mutations in  our body our children don't inherit  those mutations right so this means that  any mutation that doesn't kill the stem  cell in the body gets Amplified as that  cell contributes to regrowing the worm  so every as a result of this for for 400  million years these planaria have  accumulated mutations their genomes are  an incredible mess their cells are  basically mixoploid that meaning meaning  they're like a tumor every cell has a  different number of chromosomes  potentially they're just they just look  look you know it just looks horrible as  an end result you've got an animal that  is Immortal incredibly good at  regenerating with 100 Fidelity and very  resistant to cancer